L
BUALMOST AS ILMMAKER, KEN
>>> RIGHT NO T LET'S
START WITH CNNNGAHN ISI - R
ANG ON
LK
>> UM, W PSE
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN, IF YOU
KE TO KEN
ISTHE SECRETARY OF STATE'SFI
OFFICENDS 90% OF
INFLAMMATORY
HERE WAS TE.LES STPRESENTER TO
SENATE PRESI KARENANN AND WARRE
THEORIST'S AANTI-VAXXER.
AR R
DR. SHIVA.
AND YET, PAID HIM TOAMINE VELOP.
THEN, THE CYBERNINJAHIMSELF, DO.
HEA LO
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE TAKEAT THEPRESIDENTIAL RAE
LOSES 204 VOTES.
AND AGAIN, AREU KN SMALL NUMBER
WHEN WE AR
2.
ARE VERY
THPR THE
COLISEUM, UM, VERY AAT
CAMPUS NUMBERS.
UM, THE -- TOUGH.
>> SO TH
TRUMP N.T YOU KNOW, THAT JUST R
PRESENTATION, ANDERSON.
THSTY WAS
CY SPAGHETTI THAT HE
I- HETA C NG ON THE
CA I MEAN,
O ABSURD.PAUCTED
RECOMMENDING LEGISLATION MOVING
FOD.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT? YEAH.IT'S -I
HARD TO SAY.
BUT  IT OBABLY NEVER GOING
E Y THE NAME C
NIN
RECOMMENDATION.N, NOT JUST ON
BUT AT TNDT OF THIRELIC, IN E
SENATE, ENH THIS ISN'T
OHEARING, HE DIDN'TT OMMENDERE
POINTS ON, ALLH RESTRICT VOTIN
YOU TALK TO ANY ELECON EXPERT.AL
EYBEEN DOING THIS
G
LY THING THAT CHANGETHE OUOMIN W
FROM CNN CHIEF LEGAL ANARED CNN
T IZONA, ALL THESE OTHER STATES
EAANUCTING THEIRKNOW,
SO-CALLED SHAM AUDITOR AUDITS.T
Y FORWARD FOR
REPUBLANP AUDITING, ING
DOUBT, KEEP SOWING FEAR?>> AI
ALARMIST ABOUT
THIS OR ANYTHING ELSE.
T IZE
HOW PROFOU T A
DEPARTURE FROM THE
AMERICAN-POLIT TTI
ONE OF OONE OF THE
RULE GAMHEN
THE END.D, THAT'
YOU CAS
L PROCES
THE END, THTH THAS
ARLY ASSNGTHAT ANY ELECTION, AN
BY D ILLEGITIMAT
THEY WILL FINDAY TO
DISCREDIT IT.
THAT'S SHIERICAN
POTID IT'S -- - IT LOOKS LIK
W MOBILIZING IN ADVANCE.
LIMITING THE RIGHT T
THEN, CREATING SYS W
SISU --  ATH L- Y
IN -- IN ITS NEW CONSERVATIVE
ORIENTATN DOES NOT SEE T
>>IO, NT, THIS IS ALFOE
TO HIS DEATH BED.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE POL  -- THE '
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THAT
.RESIDENT BIDEDN
YOU KNOW, STIN TRM
FAIR ELECTIONSG RW
>> IT --WILL CONTINUE AND
-- THIS IS THE REASONT T.
DONALD TRUMP STAE
IDEA TT  THE
ELECTIONLLREASONS.
ALSO, IT WSO
DECLAR
GROUP OFPLILLING
T S TU
Y, HE IS
ENTH PM IN A
BEER
PRESIDENCY THAT HEEA T INSTITUT
VORSH IS ETI
ARE RIGHT NOW.WHE SAYS, T.
AND ANYTHINGTH.
AND THEN, FINALLY, AS YOU
ALLUDED TO THEIR COMING
WITH ALL OE ON
OUIONS TO  SPECILLPER
MO
UMI THINK THAT THEY --TH THIS I
THEYRE FUNCTL. AHE ELECTIONS WC
ARGUMENT SOME ARE MAKING,
KIRSTEN,NO
IS WE CAN'T TRUST BUT
IT'S JUST THAT SO EOPLE
FEELT USREFORE,
WE NEED TO ACT BECAUSE SO MANY
AY THAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT R
I MEAN, 'S INSANE.
S --EAIT'S -- IT COMPLY  IS --
SOMETHING 'S BEEN BUILDING
FO TIME.
REPUBLIC FTIME,
WERE CLAIMING THAT DEMOCRATS
WERE, YOU KNOWREGISTOPO , MIEY
WE HADLL THE -- THE
AND SO, THEYE LANTING RN MANY
THIS SEED A E THAT DEMOCRATS AR
STEALING ECTR DEMOCRATS
DOMETHING TO DISRUPT
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
UPTING THE ELECTORAL
>> BUT -T ONES
WHO ROL THE ST.OING ON.
IN MICHIGAN, IN PENNSYLVANIA
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE IT
HARDEROR LOR TO VOTE, POOR PEOP.
BUEV BTHAT,
GOINNG
PROCESS, ITSELF.
ANTHUM
N ESCALAON
THIS -- OF- OF ESE AND IN MANY E
WHHEAT THE COURTS DO
ABOUT IT
BUT THE ERPRCH. LSWH'S
UNMET  -ING DONEY  MAN
REPUBLICANS -- UM -- IY  IBLY -
RNE CASTING VOTES L SIDE D DEMOO
KNOW, THEIR PRESIDENT DID NO
MEAN, HE -
THE CYNICISM A-- KIND OF SO
SHAMELESS AND BRAZEN
>> YEAH.
AN ATTACK ONEMD
AND IT'S SOM
.OPLE SHOULD SEE WHERTHS ADED.
HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC.
ING TO LDI
VOTE.IT'S -- IT'S ONLY GOING
ETTH FOR REPUBLICANS TO
NEVER NCSTYOKNATLYE
THEIR -- THEOT CONDETHAT HE LOS.
AND Y OF
REPUBLICANS
AND -- AND -- AND BELIEVING THA
PRESIDDEMOCRACY CAN'T WO DOES TR
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?I -- AND I DON
.
YOU KNTH- THESE
A LITTLE MORE  YEAR.CONDUCT A E
ING TO SEEHE
GOING  WHETHER AND HOW
THEY -EY
TO SKEW ITOR.
O
LEADERSHIP IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY EX FU KNOW
JANUARY 6th THAT MITCHNNELL, THA